Harry we've been talking about Paul's
first letter to the church at Corinth
we've talked a little bit about what was
going on at Corinth talking a little bit
about how Paul is now we come to the
first two chapters of this 16 chapter
book help us think about two things that
will be helpful to us I think first
thing is how does Paul start his letters
there's a kind of formula to this and
secondly what's going on in this church
that might inspire this letter okay Paul
begins most of his letters with a formal
greeting and usually tips us off to some
of his major concerns when he gives us
this greeting so here in first
Corinthians 1 Paul called to be an
apostle by Christ Jesus by the will of
God and I brought the Safa niece to the
Church of God that is in current those
who are sanctified in Jesus Christ the
issue of sanctification is going to be a
critical one for Paul call to the to be
Saints the calling of this church is
going to be important for Paul and then
the second thing that he usually does at
the beginning of a letter is to give a
little prayer of thanks and that begins
in verse 4 and here - who usually
continues to set the theme that he's
going to be working with or lay out a
couple of the issues that come up in his
text so I give thanks to my god always
for you because of the grace of God that
has been given you in Christ Jesus for
in every way you've been you have been
enriched in him in speech and knowledge
of every kind so the status and the
quality of this community of very
important issues why because they are
divisive issues the next thing he points
to in chapter 1 verse 10 is that there
were divisions in this truth and the
most obvious way in which there are
divisions is that there were people who
were relating to different apostles and
he says as much here in verse 12 I
belong to Paul or I belong to Apollo's
or I belong to Cephas or even I belong
to Christ
these are apparently slogans that people
in this congregation are using now why
are they latching onto different
apostles probably because they value in
different ways the gifts and graces that
they have and what these gifts and
graces are is going to be an issue
throughout and Paul is going to be
strategizing throughout this text to get
them to think beyond the narrow points
of view or vision
they have of themselves and of their
status and of their own personal
relationship to God and he's going to
try to focus them on values that they
share at least that's the way I like the
first text is there anything else that
you see here him well the thing that
strikes me as you as you say this is
that Paul's inventing church as he goes
along that he doesn't have bottles of
people who've gone out starting Gentile
churches to figure out how you do these
things so he may be surprised by the
fact that X years after he was there
suddenly this church which he left I
assume thinking they all knew where they
were on the same page are suddenly
having these odd little parties part of
schisms not celebrations and trying to
figure out how he can bring them back to
what he thinks is their central vision
it's a hugely pastoral problem and even
though I think we I think attempts to
figure out exactly what the Peter party
was saying or what the Apollo's party
was saying or are doomed to failure what
we do see is this very odd connection
between a congregation and a
particularly der and somehow an
identification as if what counts is the
apostle or the leader or the preacher
who was most important to me and Paul
saying that's not the central issue
that's not where we find our identity
mm-hmm I think that's right but I think
focusing on one of these other apostles
can clue us into one of the issues
that's going through this text we know a
little bit about a Paul you know a
little bit about us from from Acts what
what do we know we know that he's is
known for his eloquence and we know that
he comes out of Alexandria which is
famous for its wisdom and speculation so
there's been some thought that maybe all
his thoughts some of this talk about the
limits of wisdom one and two Paul's
anxiety about his own eloquence two
comes from the fact that what he's heard
from Corinth is you should hear Apollo's
he is extraordinarily eloquent and
further boys extraordinarily wise PS how
are you we miss you what a great what a
great readers love is and hope it's
going well for you over there whatever
now there doesn't however seem to be a
rivalry between there's no or if there
if there is Paul's downplaying it if
they are establishing a rivalry he's
trying very hard not to do that I think
yeah he refers to Apollo's at the end
saying sending greetings exactly
exactly so they see things more or less
in the same way we hope but there is an
issue they're being ready to receive
yeah and the issue of wisdom and
eloquence seem very important now is how
do you read Paul's eloquence here in
these first couple of chapters because I
think he's he's extraordinary
well second Corinthians picks up some of
his opponents later in the story say his
letters are great but when he shows up
he's not very good I have a theory which
I will not try a new which has nothing
to do with the rest of our conversation
and therefore we will move right on I've
always wondered whether the thorn in the
flesh was some kind of speech difficulty
mm-hmm that what if you're a preacher
what would you most pray for that you
could stop stammering and that that he
knows that's the problem and it doesn't
go away and he still has it I have no
idea but I've wondered about that at any
rate as a speaker he sometimes thinks
his eloquence is not up to Apollo's
what's interesting though is that that
perhaps defensively perhaps self
defensively but nonetheless rightly he
says that it's not the eloquent with
which you preach that counts to make it
gospel it's the content of what you
preach and the content of what you
preach has to do with the cross with
Jesus crucified and we begin to get here
in 1st Corinthians 1 and 2 what's what's
going to be very important in a number
of his letters which is that the center
of good news is this crucifixion and
later this resurrection event and I'm
gonna help you help ask you to help me
on this that this undercuts all the
usual standards by which we judge human
endeavour including eloquence and
including wisdom right Paul insists on
the the ironic quality of the gospel
that he's preaching right there's glory
in this gospel there's power but this
power is revealed on the utter weakness
on a weakness in the body of a person
killed for political purpose exactly
mm-hmm and somehow they the wisdom of
God the glory of God the power of God is
there is right there
and it's we have no sense of his earlier
history except he was proud of being a
good Pharisee but surely part of what
must have shocked him about the
Christian story was that for somebody
who was so devoted at the law the claim
that God had use an outlaw executed as
an outlaw as the center of God's
revelation is scandalous absurd and
therefore foolish mm-hmm yeah there's
another dimension here today and
the polemic or the edge that Paul as is
honing I think with his rhetoric and
that's the issue of spirituality and
apparently there's some concern with
this and probably some claims to be
spiritual people on the part of some of
these Corinthians and it may be based on
their ability to interpret scripture to
understand things in a more exalted way
and Paul is trying to suggest that
there's a different criterion for
understanding what true spirituality is
all about and here he uses that symbol
of the Cross themself absolutely he'll
unpack that and all sorts of interesting
some of it will have to do with
orientation to other members of the
community some will have to do with the
way in which you read scripture some
have to do with the ethical judgment
what does love look like how do you
think that the gifts issue and the
wisdom issue come together I mean this
is this a kind of theological package
where they say we are particularly
gifted and one of our particular gifts
is that we are able to discern the will
of God through our own wisdom are these
two different issues I think they're
related it's a little difficult to tell
and sometimes Paul may be reading the
situation in in Corinth and importing
some things into what that aren't there
I think there probably is a connection
you know one of the difficulties in
reading a text like this is that we're
getting one huh - waking and if we had
the Corinthians in front of us they may
have a slightly take on how all of those
things are hanging together but from
Paul's point of view at least I think
there is a connection that he sees
between the different problems that have
been posed to him and we also get some
sense by the way in this opening of
first Corinthians of how he's getting
his information you tells us in verse 11
that khloe's people have brought him
some news Chloe a woman's name you're
probably a well-to-do perhaps
businesswoman in Corinth sending her
people people she can afford to say
that's right so freedmen or saves who've
gone over to Ephesus and it brought Paul
some news and apparently he's also
received a letter from the Corinthians
he refers in chapter 7 to what they had
written to him about and so they opposed
to him some quest
and so Paul is probably piecing together
from these questions in these reports
some sense of the overall shape of the
community at this time and probably
making some connections between some of
the things that they're asking him about
and some of the reports that he's heard
and then offering a different visual
yeah well both I just want to hold that
both those things for a minute part of
the fun of first Corinthians for me and
one of the reasons I love to teach it is
that through these stuff from Chloe's
people and through the letter we get a
closer we don't get a full picture of
how it felt to be a Corinthian but we
get closer because we ingest it we get
glimpses echoes of what they've actually
said to him that's unique in first
Corinthians and I think that the second
thing is a totally unanswerable puzzling
question where might the Corinthians be
right I mean where did they have a point
because this is Scripture of course and
they're not right Chloe's people reports
now scripture we don't have the letter
and this is the Blessed st. Paul so he
must have it right at all times I
suspect that was much more unclear for
the Corinthians
they had their opinions he had his
opinion Apollo's may have had a slightly
different opinions and one other thing
that I think we need to throw into the
mix some of the problems that are being
generated in Corinth are coming from
Paul's own teachers absolutely
absolutely makes a little letter that he
and that they interpret him and perhaps
misinterpret him so that part of what he
has to do is go back and say I didn't
mean by that what you think I meant by
that because you're drawing the wrong
implications of it but let me try this
on you it seems to me that part of his
worry is and that we'll see if heard
this all the way through that they they
have rightly heard that life in Christ
is brand-new life and they have perhaps
wrongly interpreted that to mean
anything goes that's a slight
exaggeration but that now that we're in
this new post Jesus experience new
creation let's just rethink all the
kinds of grounds by what you've gotten
along with our society and along with
our neighbors and part of what I think
part of what I think he's trying to do
is kind of rein them in I mean if in
Galatians he's tried to make Christians
freer in first Corinthians he's trying
to make Christians more responsible I
think that's part of what happened in
this letter I think that's right on and
we'll watch how he does that oh good